so Donald Trump has suggested if
nominated for speaker of the house he
will accept he didn't say explicitly he
would he said he's going to do whatever
would be best there are a lot of big
names but he did not come out and say no
no I'm running for president it's been
it's been back and forth some people
have reported that after Trump you know
they floated his name as a nominee that
he said no I won't do it then he said
yes maybe I do it now we actually have
the video where he's like well you know
we'll do what's best for this country or
for the party and so that's a that's a
maybe I think it be interesting and I
think considering the political attacks
against him we have news now from
Newsweek that a former attorney out of
New York is saying that they could
auction off the worst case scenario
already happened the dissolution of the
Trump organization and the state may
actually seize an auction off the
properties and I don't know how much
that's legit or just some dude being
hyperbolic but it's getting crazy out
there Mike cernovich warned you Scott
Adams warranted you and and I said maybe
a bit aggressive fair but we now have
reporting from Newsweek that the FBI has
created a new extremist category and
that is Donald Trump's Army of Maga
followers that's right if you are a
trump supporter that's it the FBI has
labeled you an extremist let me stress
say it again Newsweek reporting the FBI
has labeled Trump's followers as
extremists okay I don't know where this
goes I have a general idea and maybe you
might think that cernovich and Scott
Adams a little over the top a little
hyperbolic and then you learn that uh
well we knew they're Prosecuting Trump's
lawyers they're issuing hundreds of
thousands of dollar fines against
lawyers who defended Trump they're going
after Trump allies they're falsely
accusing people across the board and
have been for a long time that's only
getting worse and now if you're a follow
of trump they're saying you're an
extremist well we're going to get into
all that and a whole lot more there's a
bunch of news today before we do my
friends head over to
timcast.net
the show is this Friday so uh might be
too late for many of you to actually fly
out uh if you needed to but it is an
honor and a privilege to have Patrick
Bet David James O'Keefe and Matt Gates
himself now Matt Gates is actually
yelling he's he's heavily criticizing
the Republican Party the speaker pro
tempore has recessed until Tuesday which
should mean Matt will be at the event we
booked this event a long time ago our
understanding is Matt will be there and
I'm just trying to be as transparent as
possible because in the event Matt Gates
who successfully led the ouster of Kevin
McCarthy as speaker in the event that he
has to stay in DC to continue the good
work that he is doing then then he's
going to and that means he won't be in
Florida but we we will work something
out but for the time being it looks like
uh it will go ahead as planned we've
heard nothing else other than you know
it looks like they're all planning to be
here and uh talk about crazy timing I it
is it is going to be absolutely
tremendous to hear from Matt himself
discussing exactly how this all went
down and his thoughts and his ideas as
he has been so pick up your tickets if
you haven't already it's going to be
great also click join us at
timcast.net Ed members only shows Monday
through Thursday we will have one of
those shows up for you tonight at 10:
p.m. and as a member you also get access
to our Discord Community where you can
speak with like-minded people there's
pre-shows there's after shows and in the
Discord you can submit questions and
even call into the uncensored show and
ask us questions so smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends joining us
tonight to talk about this and so much
more is Mike Benz hey guys thanks for
having me you want to get up to the
microphone oh yeah no thanks for having
me uh um this uh this speaker move with
Trump sounds
particularly uh cinematic I mean if if
you look that's one way to put it if you
look at the powers of the speaker I mean
there's a certain irony because the
speaker is in control of counting the
votes so Trump will actually have his
sort of dream come true of being in
charge of the counting of votes after
the uh the last election cycle but then
all the committee assignments and the
power from there to be able to determine
who's on every committee I mean that
that's a that's a power you know he
didn't even have his president that
would just be kind of crazy the budget
gets investigated too do you want to
introduce yourself and the work you do
yeah my name is Mike Benz I'm the
executive director of foundation for
freedom online our job is to uh restore
the Golden Age of the internet um which
we all know and love and uh in that
Spirit that's right on that's what we're
doing censorship and other issues like
that so we'll certainly talk about a lot
of this stuff so thanks for hanging out
Lukowski of course is here hey guys my
name is ler Kowski of youtube.com/ we
are change and today I am wearing my
Biden 2024 shirt with him in a power
pose which you could exclusively get on
the best political shirts.com and
support my Independent Media
organization and uh before we start a
serious question um what do you guys
call an Irish cathic with 400
girlfriends what come on a sheep farmer
and oh goodness Sheamus cogin is also
here from from feeding Tunes I uh I
really appreciate the confidence of not
ironing a shirt that you're going to
wear before you try selling it on air
it's pretty
impressive okay happy to see you buddy I
missed you a lot Jam are you what do you
do well uh I was gone from this podcast
for quite a while I'm a recurring
co-host I'm most well known for YouTube
channel I run called Freedom Tunes I
make animated cartoons the people love
them much more than the content over at
we are change which is unfortunately
not the best stuff on the internet um
I'm happy to be back here this is my
first time on the show in a couple
months so if you've been watching this
show for a couple months maybe you
remember me maybe uh maybe you're a
friend I haven't made yet if so go over
to Freedom tunes on YouTube and
subscribe you can also go to our web uh
website and become a member Freedom
tunes.com if you like what I'm saying
and want to support what we do uh not to
throw too much at you I'm also a podcast
host I have a podcast which is exclusive
to rumble called shamer if youall want
to go over there and subscribe to that
as well thank you so much and I'm
looking forward to a great non-hostile
show with my friends who don't say mean
and horrible things to me I'm glad I'm
sitting between you guys I speak facts
I've never heard you stay a single fact
in your entire life I don't know about
that but uh fake news
Luke okay how's it going Tim I've missed
you just let there be a little bit of
Silence the the aw so he can so he can
think about what he's done all right how
about we talk about the news that we got
today we have this story from tg.com
Trump comments on whether he would
accept house speakership several House
Republicans have nominated the former
president for Speaker of the House Trump
was nominated for speakership by several
House Republicans after California rep
Kevin McCarthy was ousted and we have
this uh here this video from the post
millennial Let's uh well I'll just give
you the quote because I we don't need to
play the full you know 1 minute and 47
second clip all I can say is we'll do
whatever's best for the country and for
the Republican party which is to say
Donald Trump doesn't want to say
outright no which is to say he would
consider taking this position if that's
what actually happens I don't think he
wants to come out and say yes of course
I'm going to do it it's going to be
great because I'm not so sure he
actually wants to do it I think he's
saying this because he putting a
placeholder in it in the event he has a
meeting with several prominent
Republicans and they come out and say
actually maybe it should be a third
party it should be you Donald and the
funny thing about this is that this was
actually a scenario proposed by a lot of
people you know a year almost a year ago
or I should say you know six or however
however many months ago when people were
talking about Speaker of the House
people were saying Trump should get a
nominated speaker this is 2022 it's like
a year ago and then after they impeach
Biden and Kamala he becomes
president I mean look anything can
happen I'm not one to make predictions
or dismiss other people's predictions at
this point it's been a crazy crazy past
couple years if you came uh to me at the
very beginning of 2020 and you
accurately predicted what the next three
years were going to look like I would
have told you that you're completely out
of your mind so I'm not going to dismiss
that it it could possibly happen what do
you guys think there's also lots of
little try to speak into the mic there's
also lots of little leverage points from
this that are kind of interesting like
you could do it on a temporary basis and
then just stack the House Appropriations
Committee to zero out the very justice
department that's do that's in charge of
the the criminal proceed I mean there's
if you Game Theory this out him in a
speaker position with
people in the in a caucus who are
willing to to back him uh it could
actually throw a monkey wrench in a lot
of of things that are being done to him
and the question is is if they raise the
stakes this way you know we we're
already seeing what the justice
department and FBI are doing the other
way I don't know if we're even going to
be able to have elections or if it's
going to go full Ukraine style uh if if
a move like that is attempted by Trump I
say screw it put him in there um I I
think it's better off than any other
politician out there the paperwork has
been officially filed to even make this
something that's going to be probably up
for a vote so uh why the hell not
Tuesday yeah yeah Matt Gates was call
saying that the Republicans were sending
everybody home to go cry about it that
it's all about one guy because they've
uh uh recessed until Tuesday which
hopefully is good for us for the event
on Friday but Matt's bent out of shape
about it saying they should they should
be doing their jobs and voting on a new
speaker and he's right I wonder what the
point of a recess is to be completely
honest what's what's the point well okay
he's out now we're going to go home no
well why wouldn't you just do your jobs
these people don't want to work yeah
politicians don't work they steal
they're professional thieves they're
Liars they're con artists and they're
people that should not be trusted with
any kind of Faith at all so uh with this
news I I think the more likely scenario
I mean we could all kind of speculate
here and talk about Trump being the
speaker of the house but the most likely
scenario here that's going to unfold is
that there's probably going to be a lot
more inviting there probably won't be a
speaker of the house and because of that
there's going to be stagnation in
Washington DC and that to me is a
beautiful thing it's a wonderful thing I
don't want government doing anything I
don't want government running my life I
don't want government telling me what to
do I don't want more regulations I don't
want more taxes I don't want more rules
I think I think the situation we have
right now is the most perfect situation
for the American people and that is a
Congress that doesn't have a speaker and
can't act you know what I'm going to be
honest I I usually I don't agree with
everything Luke says I think often times
he gets things wrong I think often even
when he says something correct he says
it in such an indecipherably difficult
to understand way that you can't make
heads or tails of it but I would agree
with most of that I'd be very happy if
the government was less able to do any
of the things but you agreed with that
point I agree with that point yeah I
think you're absolutely right about that
I think you're absolutely right about
that the problem is the house is the one
branch of government right now that
Republicans control and you're you're
basically defanging the one thing right
now that's doing oversight hearings on
everything from Co Origins where just
got released that the CIA was bribing
analysts to change their you know to
change their analysis on Origins that
they were shering uh fouchy around into
these secret meetings on it and you all
this is and on the censorship side there
were so many uh things like the Jim
Jordan subpoena to get all that if you
neuter the house you sort of neuter the
resistance to the federal agency so I'm
not I'm more on the put Trump in there
than than shut it down I I think the
more like scenarios that no one's going
to be in there and to the point that you
brought up g i i do wonder why the CIA
was bribing analysts to cover up the
origin of the sickness that we all had
to deal with that Echo Health Alliance
and their organization and other CD
parts of the government were involved in
as well I wonder why they were trying to
cover up exactly what happened to the
people of the world with that particular
sickness that they had their
fingerprints on I I just want to mention
Something Mike I think it turned me
around on this one I agreed with Luke a
moment ago but I think I'm on team Mike
here I would more say that very
political answer that's what a
flip-flopping politician would do I'm
willing to change my mind based on new
information I think he made a good point
I hadn't considered it when when you
were speaking my role here is I'm the
arms Supply in the Ukraine Russia War
here so just whoever can get the arms on
their side to to win and I'm happy to do
that but as what what luk you just said
is really interesting about the
relationship between Eco Health Alliance
because you knowed they were involved I
mean it was more than involved us Aid
paid them $53 million and USA has a very
long history as being a conduit for CIA
activity oh yeah um and you know there's
there's a lot more on that on that
particular thing so so is a suggestion
that Trump as Speaker of the House would
be as ineffective on a lot of core
issues it's more like if there's no
speaker then there's really no ability
to have uh committees functioning in an
effective way and some of the push back
right now on the censorship space coming
out the oversight committee Judiciary
weaponization house Homeland Security
all of that is house driven not Senate
not you know not outside only they can
really get access through subpoenas to
some of the sensitive documents but but
people got we the kind of decisions of
what's Happening here because a lot of
people are very critical of of the house
saying specifically they they gave Biden
an unlimited budget they're not
investigating his family they're not
investigating fouchy they're not doing
what they're told they're rolling over
and allowing pure just pandemonium
allowing the Democrats to essentially
have their way with them and some people
are arguing okay maybe we'll get some
committees and some investigation but is
it worth an open border is it worth uh
you know the possibility of World War II
is it worth uh you know unlimited
spending destroying the US economy from
the inside is it worth it how is it that
the Republicans win a majority and it
doesn't change it is the same thing as
it was under Democrats and that is why
it was right for Matt gates to remve
Kevin McCarthy at the very least we get
obstruction and if you remember when the
Republicans won the house that's the
same exact point we made on this
particular show saying about this
particular situation everyone was
celebrating everyone's like we did it we
got the Republicans in not buy as much
as we wanted and thought but we did it
and I'm like this is going to be
Irrelevant this is not going to matter
this is going to be Politics as Usual
and that's exactly what what what
happened until Matt Gates got involved
and said you know what I'm actually
going to try to represent some of the
will of the American people that are
discontented pissed off with Congress
screwing them over but so and and yes
and that's that was my point we kept
saying on this show we want the
Republicans to win more so for the
establishment re anti-establishment
reasons but even if they do we realize
nothing's going to change and it's and
it is to a certain degree worse than
that what happens is when Democrats get
in They smash and Destroy when
Republicans get in they run secret back
room deals with Democrats to smash and
Destroy there is no opposition party in
this country with the Democrat do is is
the machine's agenda and the Republicans
are a pressure relase valve for
Americans who are sick of having the
boot stamped all over their face but
they can't stop it now you get Matt
Gates and seven other Republicans who
are saying now we can can put some
pressure on this system and make these
changes with tremendous tremendous power
because they're willing to push back on
Republicans on the establishment on uh
the leadership and they do and boy are
they all losing their minds you know
look I like Lauren bber marer Taylor
green Thomas Massie but I've lost a a
decent amount of respect for them I
still like them they still do good
things but they're they illogical
defense of Kevin McCarthy they have no
justification and I I will spare no one
this there is nothing no logical
argument to the American people who
despise Congress to the to the tune of
82% disapproval for them to say we're
going to keep on keeping on and kick the
can down the road the only thing I if if
I was in Congress there's no argument
you can make yeah but we're making small
gains here and there Kevin McCarthy's
getting us this that I'd be like nope
the American people despise Congress
they're sick of everything that is that
of how this machine is being run and the
omnius spending bill is basically every
single uh September Congress spits in
the face of the American people and
laughs about it and then finally when
someone says Matt Gates and these other
seven Republicans hey you know what
we're going to give a middle finger at
the very least to the Speaker of the
House who wants to maintain this system
because the negotiations work he wasn't
going to do this then what do we see
Thomas Massie say if you do this this
institution will fail good Thomas Massi
I don't think you can make an argument
to me maybe you've got Insider knowledge
but it doesn't matter to me I'm not in
Congress and I don't care other than
there is garbage in these Omnibus bills
massive funding for ridiculous garbage
internationally funding for war that's
never been Justified to the American
people and then you say we should worri
about the institution failing I don't
care I literally don't we must rebirth
that institution and maybe it should be
it should fail so that we can go and
cleaned up and rebuild
it uh nuk Gingrich also had a very
interesting response to all of this he's
a Bohemian Grove member that came out
today and said that what Matt Gates did
is quote childish and that he should be
ousted from Congress and if you look at
the people who are outraged by this you
look at CNN who surprisingly is also
pissed off at this news they have a very
interesting article that's titled
McCarthy became the latest victim of
Trump's extreme GOP Revolution what that
makes absolutely no sense at all Donald
Trump actually stood
behind uh the Speaker of the House Kevin
McCarthy many times during the original
fight for him to be speaker of the house
even just recently and and now more
importantly if you look at all the
people freaking out a lot of them are
usually connected to the military
industrial complex a lot of them beat
the drums for war a lot of them want
more war in Ukraine and uh I think this
is the big kind of lynchpin issue that
broke this damn well here's here's the
article in Daily Mail N Gingrich calls
for the GOP to expel Matt gates for
being an anti- Republican and slams his
childish behavior I've not I'm not a
republican I've never been a republican
I don't like Republicans but I voted for
them in 2020 because of Donald Trump
because of his second term agenda and
because wokeness and the far-left and
the Democrats have completely lost their
minds to the point where it's actually
kind of worrying but when Kevin McCarthy
Works secret back room deals with
Democrats to give them their funding on
Ukraine whatever the garbage they want
because they won't just commit to
actually debating bills in Congress well
then you might as well just have
Democrats in control once again so I
look at Matt Gates and the Coalition he
is leading they represent a new faction
of Voters just because GOP or R is
slapped on their title does not mean we
agree or even like the Republican party
so when n Gingrich comes out and says
Matt Gates should be expelled no I I I
say actually Kevin McCarthy should be
expelled it's this is all Kevin
McCarthy's fault all of it the shutdown
threats him getting him getting removed
from from the speakership it is not the
fault of Matt Gates if Kevin McCarthy
says he wants to be in charge he wants
to be the boss and then in exchange for
leadership he he gives guarantees and
then violates those guarantees he
screwed up nobody else did well this is
huge and this is what the media does all
the time whenever a person in a
particular position of authority fail to
live up to the obligations that they
incurred by stepping into that position
the media in the establishment blame
those who pointed out that that person
failed and then tried to remove them
from their position for people losing
respect in said position when of course
it's the exact opposite people don't
rally behind removing these people from
these positions in the vast majority of
cases because they themselves decided
they wanted to delegitimize this
institution or position it's because
they're not doing what they're supposed
to do so we saw this when attacked the
media repeatedly for very good reason
and the response was Donald Trump has
undermined American Trust in our
institutions and not these institutions
have undermined trust in themselves and
Trump is now giving a voice to that so
similarly Gates pointing out and doing
what he could to oust McCarthy does not
mean that Gates is responsible for the
fact that the American people have lost
faith in that institution or pushed him
out it's really more a product of uh
McCarthy's own actions catching up to
him did gingers give any more reasoning
for for you know for that you know in
terms of the the need to keep McCarthy
on did he spell that out in detail
because you know there is this divide
between the stakeholders in the American
Empire and the interest of the people
who live here that is sort of the fault
line as I see it uh in in the GOP Civil
War you know you have this this
Generations old GOP power base which is
tied to the military it's tied to the
energy sector it's tied to the
intelligence services and these are f
folks who you know from oil companies to
military contractors make their money on
the expansion and protection of assets
and foreign lands and sometime around
the 9s there became a a very noticeable
cleavage between the kind of trickle
down economic ideal of those
corporations sort of spilling into the
middle class to having this kind of
divide between the American Homeland and
the Empire where the people in the
Homeland were suffering as the even as
the empire grew and expanded and what we
see right now in in the Republican Wing
is you can pretty much tell whether or
not somebody voted for or against
McCarthy by whether they they represent
the foreign policy establishment or
whether they they represent domestic
interests the the Democrat Party is
completely coralled on that on that
front there's division on on the GOP my
concern with this is since I don't fully
understand the logic of of the McCarthy
back you know why it is that folks like
like genrich um are so are so insistent
on it I wonder if without compromise to
that blob people are afraid of you
know they don't really have a mafia on
their side the the bush wi of of the
Republican party you know I I think
protects there's strong representation
in the justice department and and in the
dod and CIA and state department there's
no represent representation of that in
the in the populist wing so there's like
no protection against attempts to use
dirty tricks to kill the careers of
Republican you know Congress people so I
wonder how much of that is appeasement
because there is no mob for the the
populist faction of the
GOP well new does represent more of a
kind of rhino establishment based
politics that of course is also
connected to many secret societies and
as he previously even said before the
main kind of problem that a lot of
people are seeing with Trump is that
he's not a part of some of those same
secret societies so what you bring uh
you you you bring up a very interesting
point because there are a lot of
populists but there also is a lot of
rhinos a lot of establishment types A
lot of people who go to the Bohemian
Grove take off their clothes worship mik
and of course have mock child sacrifices
that are the good old boys the good old
Republicans the cons the Christian
conservatives that of course value
traditional uh you know ways which is
which is kind of ridiculous when you
look at the face value of what they're
responsible for because when they had a
seat at the table when when uh uh when
2001 happened they had everything they
had the Senate they had Congress they
had the presidency they had the American
people behind them and what did they do
they failed the American people and I
think there's a huge section of uh the
populace that realizes holy cow like
like these guys the these guys could be
just as bad as the Democrats here we
have to speak out against this and I I
could understand your kind of sentiments
here but when looking at the current
situation that we're in the left side is
pretty bad the right side it's pretty
bad too so so I think this is the
current predicament that a lot of people
are left in kind of questioning and
wondering uh where do we go from here
either side we go on we're kind of
screwed here and the politicians who are
going to be put into place are going to
be puppets of the establishment that are
going to be doing the
screwing it's all about the interests of
those with money and it always is
there's supposed to be the will of the
people involved in our system but it's
not supposed to be direct democracy but
now we've we've I shouldn't say now but
we've been in a system for quite some
time maybe even a 100 years where it's
literally just ruled by Elites if you
have the money then you make the rules
if you're a regular person your your
ideas don't matter and some may argue
that there's a meritocracy in this like
well if you if you work hard enough and
you're smart enough and you make all
that money well then you will get an
outsized voice it makes sense those of
Merit and capability the problem is the
purpose of our government was that the
opinions of people who work regular jobs
and live humble lives matter as well and
for the longest time they've not
mattered at all in our in our in our
politics so while I agree you know
someone like Elon Musk they're like how
does he have so much power how does he
buy you know X how does he assert this
Authority well you know he he built out
these companies he made lots of money
and then he uses that you know what he
built and the resources he's gathered to
have that influence that's fine I accept
that but our our system of government
the the the the neocon neol
establishment has basically just said we
are fine with not allowing anyone of
humble means to have a voice
period yeah and the fact that they've
overturned 2 and a half centuries of
precedent to you know basically charge
Trump with 750 years of and and Trump is
now winning in the general polls
according to uh Washington Post ABC from
I think Chen yuger had like a freakout
over this that they need to be up like
15 points to be able to win in the
Battleground States and just like an
outright General uh ahead uh and you
know the guy is facing 750 years in
prison this was something that we never
even put a toe over that line before and
it and not just him it's 19 I mean all
of his lawyers they rolled up 19 at once
I mean they basically indicted the
entire Inner Circle uh around that
period in January and you know this is
sort of happening around the globe in
democracies at least around NATO now
where it's becoming shockingly common
practice to just ban your opposition
party and you know Imran Khan's arrested
bolsonaro they arrested Marine Le Pen
they they they arrested salvini every
populist leader there seems to be an
immune system uh with the foreign policy
establishment that when a populist
leader Rises to power uh for the
interests of the people who live there
rather than the interests of of the
international you know assets that they
hold or resources or Investments then
there is a sort of immune system within
the justice department or within the
National Security State to use dirty
tricks to to take them out and there's
no there's been no adaptation in the
past several years on the populist side
I mean you can see sentiment Rising but
what is there to protect Matt Gates when
he runs for governor if he starts to win
I mean you can easily imagine you know
Merck Garland taking him for something
the FBI went after Gates just recently
and they're investigating him on a whole
bunch of BS ethics garbage and the the
argument they're making is that Matt
Gates is only going after Kevin McCarthy
because McCarthy won't stop the ethics
investigations into Matt Gates and uh
that doesn't seem to make a whole lot of
sense it actually seems inverted that
the reason their investigations in thead
Gates is because he has been continually
pushing Back Against the Machine and
refusing to play ball why is it that so
many of the supposed anti-establishment
Republicans all of a sudden lost their
balls and started just dropping to their
knees for Kevin McCarthy I have to
imagine when they watched investigations
launch into Matt Gates they said please
I'll do anything you say because the
threat of total Shameless weaponization
is now very much on the table I think
that that it was easier to be emboldened
and to take on the establishment when
you assumed a certain fair play a sort
of you know
Mark of the Queensbury type thing like
okay they're going to rail me in the
press or they're going to go after my
donors not like they're going to
physically lock me up uh and subject me
to tens of millions of dollars of legal
bills uh for you know jaywalking uh in
my home District yeah well I think a lot
of this is a product of the fact that
the media doesn't have the kind of power
that it's traditionally had so in the
past if they did write those hit pieces
on you if they did smear you if they did
tell the American people that you were a
big big bad racist then it was quite
possible that your political career if
not uh being entirely over was going to
be in some substantial way negatively
affected by those accusations but as the
American people have woken up and seen
that the entire press apparatus is
controlled by One Singular set of
interests and they're going to do
whatever they can to keep the people who
they're profiting off of being in power
in power and they're going to smear
anyone who's anti-establishment who
stands up to them they've realized okay
this press apparatus isn't actually
working for us the way it used to
because it no longer has legitim and the
American people no longer trust it so
what's left after that you actually have
to take legal action in order to silence
dissident or stop them from running or
affecting any substantial political
change because you're not able to
assassinate them in the court of public
opinion anymore that's a great point
it's like as the Press power has dipped
the immune system is is sort of achieved
a kind of static equilibrium by dipping
into the the prosecution power where the
press used to do it well that's that's
desperation press power is soft power
scare people will make you sound stupid
make you look bad we'll we'll get you
shunned then when that power starts
failing they panic and now they're using
Brute Force the problem with brute force
is that it creates more stress on the
system you're already losing confidence
when you lose your your propaganda
machine now when you start locking
people up is when people stop believing
in your system yeah yep I was flying uh
uh when I was flying to Ukraine actually
several years ago we stopped over in
Moscow we uh I was flying from the UK to
Ukraine and the only flight we get was
transfer in Moscow and then to um to Kev
and the funny thing I noticed is that
when you board a plane in anywhere in
the United States they say now boarding
group one or actually depending on the
airline they'll be like coner key and
Military blah blah blah and people with
disabilities then group one then group
two and what happens everybody gets up
with their group some people might try
and push their way forward or pretend
like they're in a different groups
someone in group three might say they're
group two but that's typically normal
when I was in Russia just transferring
through Moscow and they said now
boarding group one every single person
ran full speed and jammed their way to
the front of the gate same thing was
true in Ukraine and I don't know if
that's true for all areas you know
airports in in in this in in this region
or whatever but I wondered if when you
have 70 years which is several
Generations under communist rule where
people are mercilessly beaten the rules
don't matter and if someone doesn't like
you they'll lie about you and you'll go
to the G
in order to survive you must play dirty
those who played dirty to bend the rules
were the ones who survived so what I
don't know if this is the case I just I
thought this I thought maybe the reason
when I'm in Kiev and I'm in Russia they
Stampede the gate and shove everyone out
of the way as opposed to in the US
taking their turns is because if you
were in the Soviet Union starving to
death or in in the Hol deore or
something like this the only way you
survived was by grabbing someone else's
bread and eating it so they've created
generations of people who think the only
way I get ahead is if I shove everyone
out of the way and then in the west
we've got a bit more soft and lazy where
it's just like well I'll just wait my
turn and not always not everywhere
obviously crime is skyrocketing but it
was just a thought that I had and so as
we're seeing this happened down in the
United States a a fracturing of
confidence in the system due to the loss
of narrative control and the abuses of
the system with no accountability their
only the only thing they can do is apply
more Brute Force y that will result in
more people thinking the system
illegitimate which will require more
brute force and then it will break apart
you know so so crazy about what you just
said is what what you just said is the
actual like strategic Lynch
pin Crux of of our us counterinsurgency
Doctrine at DOD which is you know when
we are occupying a foreign country and
we are trying to transition it to a rule
of law phase but it's it's being
destabilized or there's Insurgent groups
and we need to sort of do a military
occupation and get rid of insurgents
there's this the Strategic end goal is
to have a sufficient proportion of the
population to perceive the legitimacy of
the rule of law system that is when the
transition can happen and the problem is
is the more control you exert on on the
population the less the perception of
legitimacy if if people don't perceive
the system is is illegitimate is is
legitimate it it raises the cost of
occupying because people don't comply
they don't submit their taxes on time
they don't trust the courts they hustle
in the way that that Tim was just saying
but what's really amazing is like
they're all of these techniques to be
able to nudge perceptions of legitimacy
this even happened in the 2020 election
the DHS fixated on the term
delegitimization for its for its
censorship demands on uh on on the
social media platforms and when people
were banned for talking about mail and
ballots it was because they they strong
armed and jaw boned the the companies to
adopt a brand new terms of service
violation policy called delegitimization
which meant anything that undermined the
perceived legitimacy of election uh
outcomes or processes anything about it
whatsoever that you thought might be
fishy uh was considered to be a
legitimization threat and they they
targeted at that level but this is how
the military targets and coerces both
physically and psychologically like
hostile foreign combatants in in Iraq
and uh in Afghanistan the fact that it's
been brought fully back back here is uh
you know is it's kind of shocking it's
it's something that we've been saying
was going to happen ever since 2011
inside of the United States when the
Republicans said we need the Patriot Act
we need to watch everything you doing we
need to violate the constitution we need
to violate the Fourth Amendment we need
to rendition people we need to send them
over to CIA black sites where they get
tortured we need to do this for your
safety and well-being and then of course
uh myself and a lot of other independent
journalists were screaming hey uh um
this power that they're grabbing right
now for themselves is going to be
ultimately used against everyone and the
war on terror has turned into the war on
the American people and it's clear as
day it it's happening more than ever
it's it's very apparent it's here and it
and it is kind of terrifying because I
it doesn't take a genius to realize that
uh you're not the good guys when you
start to arrest your political opponents
and lawyers you're not the good guys
when you censor speech you're not the
good guys when uh of course you use
brute force to enforce your political
views onto other individuals and then
punish anyone who doesn't believe what
you believe in so I I I think this is a
very interesting turning point in
American history that is not for the
best in my opinion let's jump to the
story from Newsweek exclusive Donald
Trump followers targeted by FBI as 2024
election near I just want to make sure
we don't bury the lead right now and I
can tell you that as 2024 Begins the FBI
is explicitly targeting opponents of the
democratic party that's all that's what
they're saying right here here's the
opening paragraph the federal government
believes the threat of violence and
major civil disturbances around the 2024
presidential election is so great that
it has quietly created a new category of
extremists that it seek to track and
counter Donald Trump's Army of Maga
followers Donald Trump is the front
runner for the Republican Presidential
nomination and he is currently leading
and favored to win the presidency based
on the current polling and they are
saying his followers are extremists the
FBI and the federal government are right
now siding with Democrats and accusing
their opposition of being extremists so
we recently heard from Mike cernovich
Scott Adams several years ago about the
risk of what happens when when things
like this occur this is the next step
this is the grain of sand in the Heap
right now your federal government is
accusing Trump supporters half the
country of being extremists oh I'm sure
they'll make every excuse in the book no
no we just mean the extreme ones
Donald Trump has 70 75 75 million or so
voters in 2020 he has the polling lead
right now which Maga followers are you
referring to no it's a blanket statement
and that's all of the people who are
following Donald Trump and you know of
course we know that the leftwing
apparatus only defines extremism in the
most honest possible terms they never
throw that word I mean that's actually
part of what's so beautiful about that
word for propagandistic purposes you
don't really need to Define it what is
an extremist do any of say you're
extremely in favor of a particular
position or you would employ extreme
ends to bring your political goals to
fruition what exactly does it mean and
what it boils down to is this is a
person who I don't like who I think is a
threat to my agenda in some way and so
I'm going to try to OU them from public
life and the public discourse without
giving you concrete reasons why yeah I
mean it I always try to use the the the
term foreign policy establishment when
when breaking down these power dynamics
for this because this is this is not
just the left it's also the the neocon
wing of the right and that's sort of
what's at at stake both at the McCarthy
thing but a great example of this is the
same day this came out Chris kevs who is
the head of the censorship division uh
at DHS who orchestrated the censorship
of the of the 2020 election the tens of
millions of posts that were censored
because of DHS initiating this whole
apparatus he just came out as a as a
national security expert and said that
Russia's new plan is to Target domestic
political support for uh for Ukraine to
undermine it so that is basically the
National Security State and Chris Krab
recently partnered with two CIA
directors on one of his new Council
initiatives and he's basically creating
a rush gate predicate for saying if you
domestically are are against more
funding for Ukraine you are echoing
echoing Putin talking points you're
you're an asset witting or unwitting of
Russia and this justifies a counter
inell Ence predicate at the FBI to
investigate You by itself because you
are you know potentially abetting a uh
you know hostile foreign nation state
this is very similar to what uh Cass
sunstein uh was writing about under the
Obama Administration where he literally
wrote a paper saying how if there's any
dissident theories about the US
government and our uh actions we have to
infiltrate those groups we have to
release disinformation we have to use
col to probe like tactics to make groups
attack each other and and uh this really
makes you wonder you know this was
talked about and I think implemented
under Barack Obama who also uh
weaponized information who also passed
many very interesting propaganda laws
inside of the United States that could
now be used for domestic purposes when
when we look at all of this I I think
we're seeing a lot of the chaos
especially within the Republican party I
think we're seeing a lot of the disarray
that we see on social media a lot of it
I think is engineered I think it's
organized and I think a lot of it is
fake and meant for a particular outcome
that outcome
is to of course make sure no one is able
to resist or speak out against the
nonsense that they're trying to push on
everyone yeah look what you just said
there's like there's so much important
stuff there because first of all cass
sunstein that that that me that memo
cognitive infil cognitive infiltration
is what he was proposing a nymous
federal agents to psychologically
manipulate uh movements to get them to
go in a certain direction uh he then
that year published a book called nudge
which is actually the foundation for
censorship techniques and so-called
interventions on social media which are
being funded to the tunes of tens of
millions of dollars by a dozen different
federal agencies for all these nudge
techniques to get people to stop reading
false and misleading news and to and to
rig algorithms and to use AI machine
learning techniques to be able to uh
create topographical maps of
misinformation communities and you know
Cass sunstein I believe is currently at
DHS and his wife is Samantha power the
head of us Aid
MH you know and US Aid is is the largest
facilitator of of clandestine operation
funding for the Central Intelligence
Agency and Ukraine is the and USA is is
the Premier us vehicle for capacity
building in Ukraine uh as well as in a
bunch of other places us8 actually
custombuilt the digital identity system
called the called the DIA app which was
called a state and a smartphone which
was it was it was funded and developed
by us Aid as a to create a digital
identity basically a counter insur Mercy
tool for political dissidents in Ukraine
tying their social media to their bank
accounts so that the US Embassy there
effectively um has basically a heat map
of when people are saying things online
that might undermine the domestic
consensus in Ukraine against uh we we'll
just say a president who who may be
influenced uh by by interest abroad yeah
it's absolutely crazy how many
underhanded techniques that they're
using simultaneously while tracking
everyone's viewpoints tra tracking
everyone's opinion and then they slowly
nudging it in a direction that they want
you to perceive that they want you to
think and this is why I think we have to
be very careful on on on and and think
critically about what we see on social
media algorithms because those are also
highly manipulated as Facebook works
with the state department works with
Intel agencies to specifically curate
information as they were even doing
psychological uh studies there trying to
manipulate people's emotions to see how
far they could go just by simply uh
deciding on what to show people and what
not to show people I actually talked to
C sunstein I brought his own document to
him and I said look you're talking about
doing all these covert underhanded
really immoral things to control the
narrative and the discourse in this
country and he said I never said it I
was like it it's right here buddy he
never and again totally denied it this
this this is the game they play you you
you these powerful governmental
officials will say something publicly
and then when it turns out bad they'll
just never said that and that's it's
it's infuriating but I guess all I can
really say is that it's our job to get
those videos and get those statements
out of the public to prove their Liars
oh and a great example of this you know
you can go to YouTube right now and type
in the search term psychological
vaccination which is which is a which is
a concept and a nudge technique uh which
is being funded to the tune of tens of
millions by the state department the dod
and the National Science Foundation and
you can see these government funded
computation mad scientists on for the
for the purpose of censorship and
stopping people from expressing populist
political opinions uh and literally they
they say that the goal is behavioral
modification and psychological
inoculation against misinformation and
and they you know they have all these
different techniques for doing it which
involved basically weapons grade they
call it pre-b punking but it's basically
like the world's most um indefensible
form of straw Manning it's like we know
they're going to be exposed to these
arguments and they're probably going to
believe them because they're probably
true but so what we need to do is is
before they hear them we're going to
we're going to expose them to a really
stupid version of it and we're going to
force feed them the talking points to
just to show all the ways that that a
little incomplete version of that is
once they've absorbed that we give them
the next part in the argument we
strawman the ever loving hell out of
that we give them talking points for
that we put they have this whole uh
concept called media literacy or digital
literacy which is also getting tens of
millions of dollars it's being rolled
out in schools something called the sift
method so that people don't even do
thinking they just shift through the top
10 results of Google and and Wikipedia I
mean they're basically training popul I
just want to this really quickly because
another way that they reinforce this is
they have Bots and sock puppet accounts
that reinforce these particular ideas to
Gaslight people to believing something
that they wouldn't naturally believe
themselves because they're thinking and
seeing on social media everyone else
likes this everyone else thinks this way
and that's how they manipulate the
conversation as well as also creating
fake ideas that are crazy conspiracy
theories in order to destroy AR before
it's even made and we'll see in say like
the New York Times as you pointed out
the stupidest version of a story someone
on the on the right typically it's how
it goes will say something like you know
Donald Trump uh was proposing Congress
pass a bill that would fund x amount of
dollars then the New York Times will
write it is the stupidest idea in the
world that we would have Donald Trump
fund X Plus y amount of dollars they add
something slightly to it which Alters
the idea they find the stupidest
iteration they find stupid people on
Twitter or they the tweets themselves
and then you'll have something like
conservatives are defending Donald Trump
having you know kicked a dog and then
it'll be some random accounts with no
followers saying Trump should kick dogs
and you're like what what what who are
these people then when it comes out that
there's a bill being passed like n dog
fighting or something the average person
has already been exposed to a fake
version of the story and they believe
the fake version that's why Ian brought
this up yesterday he said as soon as he
saw one story came out he knew he
immediately had to call his mom and stop
her and tell her what was going on
before she saw the fake news
well that's exactly every single
operative in the field of Miss and
disinformation studies starts from a
first premise and they talk about this
so openly that if people are exposed to
misinformation flush if it if it hits
them full on and there's not an
intervention or or some sort of of
filter or some sort I mean this is the
whole reason that they started doing
fact check fixing to social media posts
so that there was some sort of
annotation so that you never got the
opposing s side's argument flush it
never landed did completely because
there was some way to add friction to it
or some way that there was you know a a
ghost in the machine essentially telling
you that's not really true even though
you're reading with your own eyes and
this is now a technique rolled out at
every level and it's getting so much
funding I mean it's it's if North Korea
did this we would we would be shocked at
even North Korea's techn technological
prowess to achieve that kind of
orwellian you know it's not even post
truth it's it's post brain power so
debunk
many people debunking usually fake do
this where they're like this st's been
debunked and they don't even there's
noing there's no evidence one day
someone will say Joe Biden did thing and
the media will say debunked yep and then
it's like how where's your evidence and
they'll just say oh that story's been
debunked they they will they will write
every article saying and the theory
pushed by pushed by Republicans comma
which has been debunked comma and it
works people are there's many stupid
people who fall for it abolutely I mean
this is not this is not just them trying
to to lie to the American people it gets
it gets much bigger and much deeper than
this this is the promotion of mass uh
hypnosis this is the promotion of of
psychological warfare that's being waged
on the American people without their
consent to deny them the truth and the
reality that they live in every single
day it's to preserve power it's to allow
the government to do whatever they want
with you but if you dare to question
what they did or or an incident where
they hurt people or where they screwed
people over or where they took your
money or when they robbed you you can't
even dare to question or ask about it
because you're going to have this
artificial intelligence psychological
warfare and and emotional manipulation
gaslighting on your butt like white on
rice saying no you're a crazy conspiracy
theorist you need to be denied access to
speech you need to be down ranked in the
algorithm and usually you are which is
absolutely freaking crazy yeah I mean so
the media is really supposed to exist in
order to solve a very serious and
important problem which is that there
are many things happening in the world
at any given moment which affect all of
us but that we simply do not have the
time to gather the information about
ourselves in order to make informed
decisions about everyone in this room
does this for a living but your average
person working a normal 9 to-5 or even
more hours than that does not have time
to sit down and sift through all of the
information about every relevant news
story even those of us who do this for a
living have to zero in on specific
topics of interest and become
well-versed in those because we can't
know everything about everything that's
happening in the news and that's why
it's so important to have a media
apparatus that you can trust but of
course we don't have that in this
country they've abuse their power and
they've used it in order to manipulate
people so they throw information at you
as as you've all expressed and mentioned
here which contains incorrect
information or which simply labels uh
information which is true as debunked
with ever actually going into it and of
course your average person I mean not
only do they not have time but even if
they did have time our brains are not
designed for us to be able to endlessly
sit in front of a screen and sift
through every story and retain all of
the information and know whether or not
we're being lied to so there's a an
important role for media and there's
also a massive obligation and they've
totally failed to live up to it in any
real sense it's not just to manipulate
people it's to mind control people and
we have to understand a lot of people uh
even in in the alternative media a lot
of people who are unsuspecting of this
are probably are probably already
victims of it yeah well the the less you
realize that the media is trying to lie
to you and manipulate you the more
susceptible you're going to be to that
manipulation one thing I do find that's
helpful if there's a particular story or
there's a particular conservative uh
talking point for example that the media
is saying is untrue and it's it's far
right and it's been debunked and it
doesn't have to be a conservative one it
can literally be anything that the media
is claiming isn't true go look at the
debunking because what they'll usually
do is centralize what they believe all
of the best arguments against that story
or position are they'll put them in one
place they'll give you their most
competent narrative Spin and usually
even that is very easy to see through
that's one thing I've done in the past
when I'm researching stories I will look
up the Articles factchecking the story
and if you can immediately see through
the fact check that's a good indicator
that they're lying to you they don't
have good arguments PolitiFact famously
had two quotes one from Bernie Sanders
and one from Donald Trump which were
effectively the exact same quote and
Bernie was lab mostly true and Trump's
was labeled mostly false that's right
they had made a comment about the
unemployment rate for I think it was
black uh young black men uh being around
like 50% or some very high number Poli
act Bernie Sanders mostly true blah blah
blah blah Donald Trump same quote mostly
false because what does mostly true or
mostly false mean it's nothing it's
nebulous it well it means useful to the
regime or harmful to the regime
basically and even even more shocking
like these the factchecking industry is
is entirely government sponsored politic
fact gets money from the US state
department pointer gets has like 65
government grants this is the National
Security State itself setting up these
gargoyles within the news media
ecosystem to censor the ability to
proliferate ideas that might challenge
the National Security States agenda a
and if we're supposed to have a civilian
run government but you now have this
kind of Quasi Military statecraft
Intelligence apparatus that if the
people want to vote for something that
they would have to be beholden to they
can in before it by basically blocking
the ability to politically organize or
to form a consensus because they can't
even speak the words to make the point I
want to jump to this story from Newsweek
Donald Trump's properties will likely be
auctioned off attorney says so where are
we where are we currently we're at the
point where the former president has
been uh is facing 91 indictments he's
been charged he is facing I guess the
rest of his life in prison his lawyers
are facing several uh it could be
decades in prison they're sanctioning
other lawyers who made arguments on his
behalf they're targeting Trump
supporters as Maga extremists the FBI is
targeting Trump's supporters if you're a
trump voter or Trump follower you're an
extremist according to the FBI it's this
is this is a leap from where we've seen
it before and now we're hearing that
after a judge summarily ruled that
Donald Trump must up dissolve the Trump
organization and several New York
companies a former attorney out of New
York is saying that likely what they'll
do is they're going to liquidate and
auction off his properties Donald
Trump's properties will likely be
liquidated and sold off at auction after
a judge found he committed fraud New
York's former Assistant Attorney General
has said so it's not just some attorney
it's the former Assistant Attorney
General Tristan Snell was speaking after
a court found that former president the
former president had massively inflated
the value some of his properties and
ordered that some Trump companies
involved be stripped of their corporate
licenses quote the worst outcome that
could have come from this case has
already been handed down and that is for
the corporate licenses to be canceled
the properties are likely going to be
liquidated the properties are probably
going to be sold at auction that's
probably what is going to happen we
don't know that for sure but that is
probably where this is headed so Trump
is already really really in trouble did
the courts prove that Donald Trump
committed fraud they didn't the uh AG
said here's our argument Donald Trump's
team said we have an argument and the
judge said I don't care Bang the gavl
summary judgment you did commit fraud
because I said so that's it Luke I'm
with you uh make this man speaker of the
house now they now they could
effectively seize an auction off his
properties and just strip him of his
wealth you know when I I don't view
Donald Trump as doing all of this for
himself in terms of financial gain cuz
he ain't getting it he's losing but I
wonder if Donald Trump is doing this for
himself because he is filled with a
blind rage and wants revenge and I'll
take it yeah I mean look he knows that
these people have done basically
everything to try to screw him over and
screw the American people over and it's
very important for the powers that be
that you as an average person watching
what's happening in the media know that
this is what happens to people who stand
up to them this is what people uh who
are a thorn in the side of the
establishment are going to have to go to
in present day America it's a very sad
situation and we have to pray for him
he's really going through a lot and I I
genuinely do believe that regardless of
whether I agree with him on everything
and there are certainly things I
disagree with him about that uh he he's
doing a lot of this because he is angry
with the uh injustices that the American
people have faced at the hands of the
establishment over the past several
decades K serin made a joke once that um
the there's so many stacking human
rights violations in this country now
that the country we used to live in
would uh would do a land invasion of the
current the country currently live in no
I mean there's some truth in that and
when you look specifically at what's
happening to Donald Trump I think you
know part of me wonders if you you
mentioned earlier that the uh system is
is attacking him right now and he is the
lead candidate running for president
right now I think those two things well
certainly being correlated it's
difficult for me to assess out whether
that relationship uh is necessarily
causal and I don't know that you were
implying that it was but on some level
it seems to me important to them to go
after the front runner if the front
runner is challenging The Establishment
on the other hand I also wonder if even
if Trump was in the last place they
would still be doing this because they
have to punish those who stand up to the
regime in many ways this is oh sorry no
no no well let me just make one one
point I think you made a a very
interesting kind of observation because
I do think if the United States saw what
was happening inside of the United
States they would invade the United
States in order to restore democracy and
rule of law so uh it's it's a little bit
ridiculous again I've been a a Critic of
of Donald Trump but this is clear
political prosecution this is clear L
them doing everything in their power to
try to stop him and they and the more
that they do that the more popular he
becomes the more people support him in
the polls the more people want him to
become president of the United States at
at what point do they realize that that
whoever they're trying to stop they're
also growing at the same time well
exactly and that that goes hand inand
with what I was saying earlier if it was
the other way around right and the media
was talking about how Trump uh actually
did nothing wrong and the system was
going after him for unjust reasons then
maybe the American people wouldn't
support him I think it's a combination
of factors people don't trust the media
anymore uh this goes uh this goes hand
in hand with what I was saying earlier
about the fact that when their apparatus
for propagandizing people fails they
have to use Force I mean he is ahead in
the polls all of the the slander has not
been effective at reducing his
popularity and so this is what they need
to do Mara Lago is not worth $20 million
that is an absurdity on its face as a
business alone with no real estate
assets it's generating more than that
per year the real estate alone even if
you want to argue that it's got
covenants or tenants restricting its use
in certain ways it is still 17 and half
acres the judge is lying these people
are evil and they are psychotic and what
they are doing to Trump to seize his his
properties to seize his money is
communism 101 yep if if this really
comes down to it that they cancel the
license of Trump's companies they lose
on appeal and then they what liquidate
and auction them off at what pennies on
the dollar to strip Trump of his net
worth welcome to a whole new ball game
ladies and gentlemen there's no way this
judge is so stupid he doesn't know that
he's lying he's just evil well and you
know for your average person looking at
this again they see Donald Trump an
actual billionaire being handled in this
way by the system and I think it could
cause them to despair to go well if he's
not able to get through this right if
he's not able to leverage the economic
power that he has to escape this kind of
political prosecution what hope is there
for me yeah and in many respects what
we're seeing is is actually worse than
an assassination we've had
assassinations in this country we've
actually never had presidents uh
indicted like this and and having their
entire lives destroyed via these
liquidations and these gang bang of
lawsuits from every direction uh but the
fact is is when JFK got assassinated or
when AB lincol got assass fascinated it
was there was not an attempt to say this
is a legitimate course of action there
was not like you could say this is a
tragedy this is horrible but it's a
one-off thing that doesn't actually make
me entirely lose faith in the legitimacy
of the system because it wasn't system
approved what we're seeing now is
effectively an assassination and don't
kid yourself he's facing 750 years in
prison that's that's death that is a
that is capital punishment uh and I mean
that's it's only 25 years for
first-degree murder uh and and he's
facing 750 without even on totally novel
legal theories so what they are doing to
the perceptions of legitimacy in in in
this country by doing it this way is
honestly an order of magnitude more
shocking I'd I wasn't a lie for whatever
was experienced during JFK but I have to
imagine that I mean how can anyone here
forget this for the rest of their lives
and there's always going to be a degree
of cold anger about what they've done to
this guy uh just for just for running
for office well so here's the question
for you guys and maybe this is just a
question of whether you see the glass
half full or half empty whether you're
an optimist or pessimist but do you
think that this is going to terrify
people and make them feel afraid to do
anything because Trump can't escape
these charges and they'll feel like they
can't or do you think this is going to
edify people this is going to make them
angrier with the system this is going to
make them want to stand up to the powers
that be uh I I don't think either I
think regular people are starting to get
scared they don't want to stand up to
anybody they want to be left alone when
uh you know I I'm hanging out with some
regular folks on the weekends just
apolitical nothing to do with this
playing at the uh the old poker tables
and uh some lib lib guy said I hate
Donald Trump but trying to get him off
the B this is getting insane MH and I've
heard sentiment like this quite a bit
from regular people who are just like I
don't like Donald Trump I can't stand
that guy but man this is getting crazy
and if you if you if you look at that
perspective and then go back to say 2020
or 2019 I from a lot of people saying
things like I just want it all to stop
Donald Trump won't shut his mouth he's
so annoying a lot of people felt that
everything happening in the culture war
and in politics was the fault of Donald
Trump Y and that if they just voted for
Biden it would all stop and it would go
back to us just plugging our ears and
watching sports and letting Obama blow
up kids and no one has to pay attention
and then it got worse not only did it
get worse the economy got worse and now
they won't stop Trump isn't even
president anymore and they're trying to
put him in prison they're trying to
seize his properties and I think now
what you're starting to re see from
regular people who thought voting for
Biden would get them out of this is
these people who got rid of trump
they're making it 10 times worse and now
it's getting very scary and I think a
lot of these people might actually end
up voting for Trump in fear thinking we
need someone to stop the extremism and
it's certainly the we were wrong voting
for Joe Biden exacerbated the problem so
yeah well I'll I'll let you guys respond
first before I uh interject with my
point do you think this is going to make
people more afraid do you think this is
going to edify them I I I think looking
at the poll numbers I I I think a lot a
lot of people are saying I'm just going
to support this guy I I think we're also
reaching a situation where a lot of
people are um having their lives upended
under this economy I think inflation has
a big deal to um to to have this kind of
sentiment of of of uh people being
pissed off people saying hey everything
I had everything I I want to achieve in
the life is becoming less and less
achievable groceries are becoming more
and more expensive under this
Administration and now they're doing a
huge power grab where they are trying to
put their main political opponent in
jail this is a bad sign for me this is a
bad sign for my country for my children
and I think a lot of them are concerned
I think a lot of them are also reaching
a point where they're uh enro
encroaching such poverty that they just
don't give a damn they don't care
they're pissed off I think I think a lot
of these people probably won't vote for
Trump but they certainly won't vote for
Biden or whoever ever the Democrat is
because they're going to be thinking in
their mind I did this last time and it
got worse I'm just leave me alone please
I'm scared yeah I mean one thing I would
say to anyone who's afraid of standing
up to the system in any kind of
meaningful way because of what's
happening to Donald Trump is that when
you appease the left you show them that
the tactic that they're using works and
they double down they only get worse
yeah it's like a little kid screaming
for ice cream exactly if the kid has has
a temper tantrum and the mom's like okay
okay you can have more ice cream it's
like well the kids's going to keep
screaming exactly they will never stop
it's not like the radical left doesn't
go okay you know we got everything we
wanted at this point we're going to stop
for a while this was the line thank
everybody exactly you gave us what we
want so we're going to go away now we
got halfway to Communism and we're going
to stop here and uh thank you for your
time and then even even when they do get
to Communism they'll say well this is
not a perfectly functioning communist
system because like you're hiding some
grain and feeding it to your family so
we have to keep pushing the ball no in
reality they they show up to your house
when there's rumors that uh you have a
chicken mhm or that your chicken died
and this is true in North Korea I uh uh
I did a a documentary with with Vice
about North Korea interviewed some
people who actually driven through it
and they explained how if a cow dies you
can't touch it the state has to come and
take the beef and distribute it evenly
among all the people which usually
doesn't happen usually what ends up
happening is it gets stolen you know it
gets sent off to the fat cats and the
people in power but if you secretly take
that animal and eat it they'll they'll
put you in the G mhm and what they said
was sometimes the local cuz everybody
has to join the military locals will
keep it a secret and then hide the
animal and hope nobody finds out or
they'll bribe the local you know
military guy or guard or whatever and
say we'll give you some beef if you just
don't say it happened exactly so this is
one of the massive flaws with Communism
and this is one thing I try to help
people understand it is true that
capitalism can result in a disordered
centralization of property but the
problem is communism results in a
centralization of property right
a small number of people get to own
things because they're connected to
certain government officials or they're
powerful enough bureaucrats or they're
able to do favors for the right people
in the proper positions of power to get
themselves whatever it is that they're
after and everyone else has no ability
to own anything they have no say they
have no control they have uh nothing to
show for their labor well I got bad news
on that front about the situation here
because the backbone of our interstate
commerce law is a case called wicker
versus filber
which Bas which Pro which was a case
that prohibited a farmer from being able
to grow you know beyond a certain amount
of food crop on his own on his own
property uh because of its impact on
interstate commerce I mean it's when
when you mentioned the cow I thought
well you know call that call that grain
and and you know that's actually the the
architect architecture of all of these
restrictions on on personal freedom on
grounds of of well it it impacts
interstate commerce and thus it's almost
like a for the collective you know for
the collective good you know there these
limitations and I'm not even saying that
that's you know there is a school of
thought there is something something to
that but um you know there's there's a
lot
of similarities to foreign uh tyrannical
systems that that uh that are very close
to this one that we're living under
right now especially when you look at
what Monsanto did with its seeds and its
pollination
that they were able to of course force
on local farms and then slowly surely
take them over and tax and regulate them
so so clearly this is a hijacked system
that just makes up the rules and laws
whenever they want and this is something
that I've been saying for a very long
time there there's counties right now in
the United States where you can't even
collect rainwater uh you can't even grow
your own food you can't even have a
chicken and that that to me is
absolutely
absurd
yep so so it was the cow in North Korea
well that was just one story I heard but
uh that's communism man you know the the
you right now you've got the AOC wanting
to increase taxes in the top 5% of
income earners in New York City arguing
that well that's all the rich people the
issue is the top 5% of income earners in
New York City make about $250,000 a year
that's that's a good money I'm not
saying these people are by any means
broke but we're not talking about the 1%
anymore what's happening is as the
wealthy leave the tax base fleas and
wealthy people pay the bulk of tax of
the tax uh Revenue the bulk of taxes so
when you start cranking up taxes and New
York City is already super expensive
because they have a city income tax
wealthy people seeing crime basically
ask themselves why am I paying a 4%
premium to live in a city that is worse
than most other places they don't they
leave now all of a sudden you're losing
all this tax revenue the city gets
strained Services get worse so what do
they do they reach deeper down to the
bottom of the barrel now they're saying
not the 1% now they're saying the 5%
this this means that if you're a dude
who makes 130k a year and you marry a
woman and you both work full-time and
you're making 250k as as a married
couple she wants to tax you more the
average rent for a one better in New
York City is like four grand so you're
going to have about 8,000 leftover and
that's not disposable you got to pay for
your food you got to pay for utilities
you got to pay for fuel you got to pay
public transport whatever that may be
and then let's say you well Healthcare
of course it's going to be another
thousand bucks or more then you got to
pay if you want to have a family okay
well you're going to end up with a
couple thousand bucks per month for
savings or something like that and again
I'm not saying these people are hurting
what's happening now is that's like
what's what was supposed to be middle
class having a little bit leftover so
you can plan a vacation for the end of
the year and have a retirement account
yeah AOC is targeted the people who are
just barely past this threshold in New
York City under the assumption that what
it's all a bunch of single childless
Millennials who are making 250k and they
got to pay more in taxes yeah I mean
even so yeah two 250k is a lot of money
but but the government is taking in
plenty of money right now and they waste
it and there's actually some evidence
that the government taking in more money
results in an increase in debt because
statistical Trends show that
historically for every dollar the
government gets in Revenue it spends
$1.33 so this is this is something we've
seen repeatedly over time they get more
money and then they spend more we saw
this with the Trump tax cuts uh as a
matter of fact the left kept arguing
Trump cut taxes and we saw a decrease in
Revenue that's not true we actually saw
a 5% increase in Revenue as a result of
his tax cuts because the economy became
more productive because more people were
working because they got to keep more of
their income and so even off of smaller
assessments even off of a a lower tax
rate the government was generating more
Revenue the problem is spending
increased 10% when that Revenue increase
went up 5% and so we did end up with
more of a deficit after the Trump tax
cuts but it wasn't because we lost
Revenue it was because they spent all of
the revenue gains my point is expect
them to keep digging deeper and deeper
absolutely after this they're going to
say the top 10% of income earners and
then eventually the top 10% of income
earners are going to be making $10 more
than the average income earner when they
flatten income and everyone in New York
is only making 15 bucks an hour who will
be the top 1% there won't be one well I
guess there will be it'll be you you
will all be the high-end you'll be
making 16 bucks an hour and you'll be
the 1% and they're going to tax you for
it so abolish the IRS right um and go
back let's go back to 193 this is a city
though New York City New York City tax
state tax and federal tax is what people
have to deal with there and on average
pay around uh I think close to what 50%
of of their income of of their personal
profits that that they of course worked
hard for why work why work when the
government's taken more than half of and
not just why work but why stay why not
go to a more rational state New York is
not exactly in a good negotiating
position right now to start asking the
people living there for more money do
you guys remember that story I don't
know if it's true or not but it's a good
story this woman had a viral Tik Tok
where she explained a professor was
talking about capitalism and communism
and issued a wager to the students
saying we'll try out communism everybody
will take their final or their their
midterm or whatever and then we'll
average out the grades and give everyone
an equal grade and they and you know a
bunch of people are like no no we don't
to do that Bunch people like yeah okay
let's do it what end up happening is the
people who busted their asses and
studied and and M and you know hit the
nail on the head with the hammer ended
up getting bees and the people who did
barely anything well this is great I got
a be then the people who did really well
and held the average high said what was
the point of doing all that work if I
ended up not even getting ahead because
of it I just wasted my time for no
reason so what happened the next time
they they ended up doing some you know
the next test that came around everyone
ended up getting a c now everyone's
pissed off and complaining about how
this is running and then the next test
everyone failed because everyone started
saying what's the point of working if
I'm not going to get ahead because of it
why would I why would I hurt myself and
and struggle and not be rewarded for it
and that's that's the problem of
Communism it's not so much I certainly
think there are Marxist and Communists
who want to ferment the system but I
think when you look at what AOC
represents there is a banality of
Communism there is the blind ignorance
of marching towards communism by people
who are too stupid and too uh uh their
first order thinkers AOC for example I
think she's she she lies a lot I think
that's evil but I also think she's
really stupid so what ends up happening
is what is she saying now she signed on
to a pledge from the Democratic
Socialist to they want they want taxes
raised on the top 5% of New York and
that's what and that's where we're at 10
years ago it was the 1% now it's the 5%
when there's no one left to tax you have
to tax every everyone else it's easy to
say the 1% they raise the taxes now the
1% leaves Revenue goes down the 5% then
the 10 then the 20 then the 25 then the
top 50% then it's class war then it's
just people fleeing and you get open air
drug markets you get exactly what we're
seeing now and once system breaks they
then come in and say give us absolute
control to solve this problem we need to
come in with strong military force and
security to clean up the streets give us
the power well and of course the irony
is that the more they tax people once
they hit that Revenue maximizing Point
uh in the laer curve and continue to go
further which they I would argue have
long ago an increase in taxes actually
starts to result in less Revenue in
certain circumstances so when things get
really bad and they start dipping lower
and lower and say stop 10 top 10% top
20% Etc what happens is not only do they
start taking in less Revenue because
people leave the city or they're they
aren't working as hard or more people
lose their job or employers can't afford
to continue to hire people then the
government has less revenue and more of
that Revenue ends up being spent on the
corrupt bureaucrats who are sabotaging
the system and trying to pull from it as
much as they possibly can before it
totally collapses so the people get a
whole lot less people like AOC they and
and these leftists they don't understand
how taxes work raising taxes decreases
tax revenue and if you're a first order
thinker not very bright you go huh it's
kind of like the people on Twitter who
are like uh food comes from the store
dude it's like no food comes from a
variety of places first there's a farm
then there is a distribution then then
there's packaging right it goes through
a lot of different phases before finally
makes it to your store but the reason
raising taxes typically will decrease
tax revenue if you have a dollar and tax
is 5 cents 5% and I give some the dollar
they got to give a nickel to the
government but they still have 95 cents
so they trade that 95 cents and now
someone's going to give you know four
4.8 or whatever or whatever the math is
another fraction so the government in
these two transactions ends up getting
slightly more than the one transaction
the simple way it works is if you tax
someone at 50% and then someone trades
their dollar you take half of it then
the next person only has 50 cents they
can't afford to buy anything so they sit
on it the government government made 50
cents if the tax is lower everyone keeps
trading all the way around until they
get down to 50 cents and the government
has taken a slightly higher percentage
so the the the easiest way to explain
this is the story I was told was that
there was a Home Depot in Cook County
Illinois that shut down and reopened in
DuPage County uh like like five miles
away and they spent a couple million
dollars to do this and the reason was
when the county raised taxes by I think
like 2% or something like 0.2% some tiny
number if you're talking about a
fraction of a percent but you're
spending millions of dollars on supplies
and orders through Home Depot for for
your Contracting work you can save a
couple hundred bucks or a couple
thousand dollars you will drive a couple
miles per day to pick up your supplies
it doesn't matter that much so what ends
up happening is they raise taxes trade
drops off now the government's getting
up percent up 50% of zero is zero MH
whereas 5% of a dollar is is 5 cents you
rather have the 5 cents but this this is
what they do this is where we're going
absolutely and I also want to point some
something out here uh about AOC Tim you
mentioned that it's what 200,000 or more
per year 250 so 250 uh AOC uh makes
what1 175,000 a year and she was
complaining that it was unacceptable
that she had $177,000 in student debt if
you're making
$175,000 a year and you're a single
person you don't have children you don't
have dependents then you should be able
to handle $177,000 in debt right we're
talking
$175,000 a year that's a lot of money
but
bro come on okay she has a Tesla you're
right she got P she has to pay that off
yeah no exactly so my point is she can't
afford this 177,000 a year even though
she makes or not 17,000 a year 177,000
total in debt when she has
$175,000 coming in each year and she's
going to sit here and lecture us about
how people could be paying more money
for social programs that they didn't
sign up for when she chose to take that
debt out herself I I will say to be fair
Teslas actually aren't that expensive
not as expensive as they used to be yeah
I think she's like a model 3 and it's
like $30,000 which it's crazy to think
because that's unacceptable that she
owes $30,000 on that cars have got it's
crazy that cars have gotten that
expensive the the the cost of cars is is
nuts right now it's great that Elon Musk
is dropping the prices of all the Teslas
repeatedly but uh it's crazy when you go
to dealerships and you see the inventory
is gone and the price is through the
roof yeah they they they you're you'll
live in the Pod and you'll eat the bugs
you'll own nothing and you'll be happy
delicious and I I I I really I don't see
how we avoid the living in the pot and
eating the bugs thing yeah do you think
only the rich will eat meat is that
everyone else on nope I think you're
going to be at a restaurant and uh
you're going to be sitting there talking
with your friends and laughing you're
going to look over the menu and you're
going to say I'll do the I'll do the
bran Zeno and they're going to go
excellent choice sir and then they're
going to walk out with a plate full of
mashed roaches and they're going to put
it down you're go ah neuralink on the
fritz and you're going to flick it and
then it's go who and then you're you're
going to see the roaches turn into a
Branzino so you are actually so
someone's going to be like I I'll do the
uh flowless chocolate cake with the
vanilla ice cream excellent and they're
going to bring out cockroach mash and
they're going to put it in front of you
and you won't see that you will see
chocolate cake and you'll be you know
eating it like oh it's so delicious and
then anybody without the noral link
they're going to see the roach legs
smatter to your face and like and the
and the roach Gunk on your face like
licking it off is there any traction
they don't even need to go that far they
don't even need to go that are they get
people to call men women all the time
they've just changed our vernacular so
much and put social pressure on people
to not disagree with them when they
State obvious mistruths yeah yeah yeah I
got a bone to I got a bone to pick with
all of your vernaculars cuz you guys
have been saying theft wrong this whole
time okay and and and this theft is so
Insidious there's there's property theft
there's sales theft there's restaurant
theft there's hotel theft there's so
much theft going on right now that that
it's absolutely disgusting because it
stops the free market
being free but also STS individuals from
solving problems and being there for
other communities and robbing them of
any freedom back to the point uh I don't
think necessarily it'll be neuralink I
don't know I think if they get to the
point where neuralink can be Wireless
this will happen but uh my point is
right now uh Taco Bell near me we were
we were flying back and we drove P we
were driving past Taco Bell and Sheamus
insisted that we live Moss I said we
have to live Moss right now over we have
to live M and we did seed oil guzzlers
did guys calm down yes okay so anyway we
went there uh on another trip we went
inside not always jamus this time and it
was kiosks they were human beings behind
the counter but they're just making food
and you go to a kiosk to
order give it 10 or 20 years you're
going to walk in a Taco Bell and it's
going to say uh you know you're going to
you're going to type in I'll do a Cheesy
Gita crunch extra sauce check out and
it's going to say neural pay and you're
going to be like uh there's nobody here
mhm there's no humans I what's I don't
have noral pay I only have my credit
card on me and it's just going to say we
no longer accept credit cards at this
time you either get it or you don't I've
thought about something weirdly a lot
and I'm curious for your guys opinion on
it what happens to the adte world in a
fully saturated neuralink world in the
sense that you know like Google
AdWords totally changed the way search
happened on the internet because it all
became all about the word you're
searching for and you monetize the
specific words billions of dollars of
advertising go into bidding on words
when the interface moves from words to
thoughts it's like I can almost it's
still words though but I can imagine but
those are going to get tagged to
basically like neural activity and
you're going to have signatures of
neural activity associated with those
words you're going to basically have
like bding on neural signatures like
very directly I think the bigger issue
with neuralink advertising is going to
be the discovery of uh uh we already
know this but the degrees of cognitive
uh faculties I suppose right the I don't
want to say IQ necessarily but there are
uh uh different different metrics by
which we uh uh assess an individual an
individual's brain capacity IQ being one
of them there's also visualization
examples the one where they show uh uh
they show an apple and they say when you
think of an what do you see yeah and
then the first one is a vivid photo
realistic Apple the next one is a you
know flat two dimensional Apple the next
one is a black and white outline and the
next one is nothing and there are a lot
of people who have responded to these
saying like you can see an apple when
you think it man some people can't some
people report not having an inner
monologue and I've met people they they
say that they don't have an inner
monologue and I'm like so what do you
think when you think like if you're not
thinking in pictures words sounds and
like visual ization what are you
thinking and they're like I don't know
just thoughts I guess what I've
experienced in talking to people about
this is that some people think in
pictures some people think in sounds
some people think in images of the words
themselves and some people report none
of this some people in their minds are
talking to themselves as they think and
some people are not some people have
multi-track minds and some people don't
so when it comes to neuralink and they
begin to try and track your brain
activity for ads it's going to
interesting when they find people who
get into neural link they're going to
say and whether you want them to or not
these these AI companies these big tech
companies if if neuralink type devices
human brain inter brain computer
interfaces become ubiquitous they will
absolutely track your cognitive level
it's going to be like the Human Genome
Project but for like neural activity you
know like to create a comprehensive map
of all the different words phrases ideas
they'll be able to attack dissonant
groups by the signat of you know it's
it's
uh the crazy thing frightening have you
seen uh have you seen Captain America
Winter Soldier I've scenes of it this is
the movie where there's a secret
conspiracy government conspiracy to uh
Mass execute dissident thinkers and the
the the plan is to launch gigantic
warships that will instantly Target
anyone who is deviant and execute them
instantly with a bunch of gun with just
like hail of
gunfire it's the
an AI will know you are going to vote
for Trump before you even consider
voting for Trump yourself it's the DIA
app we installed in Ukraine I mean in in
a sense Facebook knows when you poop
right Facebook knows when you're going
to go to the bathroom before you even
know you're going to go to the bathroom
because it it AI is truly remarkable it
sees things that we don't notice right
when you go outside and you look at the
actually one of my favorite points to be
made to people there's two stories the
one is the Native Americans on the
islands in the in the Caribbean and the
Bahamas could not see Christopher
columbus' ships they their ships were on
the horizon headed towards the island
and they didn't know what was happening
despite them being there visible plain
to any human they did not register until
there were like there was like an elder
or Shaman who was sitting there watching
the waves and then one day looked up and
said there's a very large boat and they
were like what where right there see it
and they were like no I don't see that
thing right there do you see it they're
like I don't I can't see anything this
is a story they tell
and the reason they they say that the
elders were able to notice it is because
many of these uh uh uh tribes and and
different civil societies would uh map
Waves by looking by by tracking the
direction of the wave you actually know
where islands are and other land masses
are so when these big ships are creating
wake and creating waves the the the
Masters were like hey wait a minute
something's there but it wasn't within
their their comprehension so what I like
to do is when I'm driving in the middle
of nowhere and there is like a a plane
or whatever let's say we're driving in
rural Illinois through the through the
Midwest as soon as I see a cell phone
tower I I'll I I would always ask one of
my friends I'm like what do you see
right now and they would go what where
and I'd be like right now right now just
tell me everything you see like uh grass
in the street the road I don't know what
are you talking about and I'm like what
else do you see what is right in front
of us what is right there like dude
there's nothing what are you talking
about I'm like the giant 40ft cell phone
tower right there and they're like oh I
didn't notice most people don't even
notice when they're driving past cell
phone towers it's out of sight out of
mind this kind of thing blows my mind
now consider that as we enter the uh uh
the next phase of you know brain
computer interface what we're going to
be tracking in people's minds what AI
can notice that you can't if we can't
even see a giant Tower in front of us
because it's immaterial to us so we
don't even register it and we don't
remember it being there think about all
of the things we miss every single day
oh yeah you run these through AI
man they're going to be able to
accurately predict weather perfectly
like right now it's like well there's a
front coming in here so this usually
means weather and there's like an
accuracy and it's like we think it might
rain n they're going to be able not only
that with a true masterful like Quantum
AI they will be able to Butterfly Effect
a hurricane they'll be able to to track
the entire global patterns by collecting
all the data and then look at all the
variables and weed it down to like how
did this hurricane form right here and
say okay we can we can we can see that
stuff it's going to be nuts yeah I I was
just going to say they won't be able to
to just predict they'll be able to
manipulate and create a lot of the stuff
that that we're having to deal with and
you know a lot of people talk about you
know weather modification being crazy
there's already uh a sence to this the
Chinese government is already using this
um and and that's one element of this
that doesn't even have to do with the
social aspect of this doesn't have to do
with the psychological aspect of this as
of course the manipulation that is
already underway probably involves
components of artificial intelligence as
we speak right now I don't know I don't
know about you but but I I I think
there's uh the possibility of a bigger
conspiracy here and and the possibility
of a lot of technology that we're not
even aware of already yet use
manipulating our thoughts and ideas as
we speak right now what do you think
well I mean just as a threshold thing
we're I was thinking about robot dogs
recently you know those like black mirr
dogs that gotten rolled out to like uh
you know now just like regular city
streets from time to time and are always
sort of threatening to be the next sort
of uh digital RoboCop to replace street
cops and I was thinking about that
recently you know there's so much
corruption in the justice department now
and there's so much like there's so many
civil rights abuses from the National
Security State and law enforcement and
and other branches of government that
it's almost like well we pick your own
adventure story but for dystopia it's
like in a way they've made things so bad
in the the analog sphere that you
almost
welcome the or the order of some of
these digital things um because you know
against the people who just want you
dead because of your political opinions
you don't have a chance I'd almost
rather have like an AI judge uh than the
guy that uh that you know Trump's up
against who like starts the hearing by
smirking for the camera um or against an
an attorney general like Leticia James
who literally campaigned on indicting
someone and you know is not like you
know recusing so you know it's the
problem is is we as we talk about like
digital dystopia the problem is the
analog dystopia is so bad now that
like we're already at 11 I mean this is
this is break already I I want to ask
you because you were at the state
department how far does the rabbit hole
go how bad is the US government oh well
we're we're going to we're going to
we're going to need a couple years
Define define bad like which what do you
mean specifically right like evil
incompetent how what what's your
assessment from the inside of the state
department how much of it is malicious
how much of it is just following orders
how much of it is just ignorance and how
sophisticated and complicated it does it
get and are we even uh able to imagine
how bad it gets my colleagues at the
state department were actually the smart
some of the smartest people I met in
government and and outside of government
there is an animating Spirit of Mackie
of ellian world Conquest that permeates
that institution in a way that it
doesn't at HUD or even at the White
House um there is a there is a sense of
the bigness of the world and the
interconnectedness of the world and the
opportunities in the world to go region
by region and um stack the deck in ways
that are advantageous to the state
department stakeholders
this is one of these things where until
the 2016 election happened and the
National Security State which had always
you know come home in so many ways you
know I mean you can make an argument
that even the Martin Luther King stuff
and a lot of the coel pro stuff was a
proxy attack on the Vietnam War you know
they the FBI only got the
counterintelligence predicate on him
because of him being backed by Stanley
leveson the uh who was said to be a sort
of communist Soviet and and you had DOD
and and CIA involvement in that FBI
activity as well uh there was always
sort of a Crackdown this but the F what
they've done in the modern era has has
actually shook
my I used to think that we've got this
department of dirty tricks you know that
we started to set up after World War II
you 1947 act we created the CIA we
changed the name of the war department
to the defense department to make it
sound like we're not doing War we create
this entire NGO swarm Army we create
these incredible embeddings between the
National Security State and the media a
soft power projection apparatus that
could effectively control the political
economies of any country we capacity
build and but there was always sort of a
sense well it's it's it's for the
benefit of the people who live here the
bigger the American Empire gets the
better off Americans are more jobs are
you know if if Chevron does well well
that's more people who's got jobs in
Texas and uh in Oklahoma you know if um
if Pepsi Co does well you know that's
more for shipping manuf there was this
there was at one point there was a
connective tissue between the people who
live here in the Empire abroad and at
some point you know pick your your
Evolution point in in globalization you
know whether that was you know in the in
the in the 70s whether that was in the
90s when the when the offshoring really
hit the hay and you know China joined
the WTO and cheap labor you there were
so many different points of departure
from that um and and but now it's almost
completely removed and there's no better
example than that of that than what's
happening with the Biden family in
Ukraine I mean it is like a state
department
operation to help a very small number of
economic stakeholders and by I'm not
even making a formal opinion on this I I
I understand both sides of the Ukraine
Russia thing that's not my my bag so to
speak I just care about freedom on the
internet but you but in order to
understand why it is that you get
censored for talking about Ukraine stuff
or political movements who are proxies
for that get censored is because you now
have a state department vested interest
in censoring us American voices because
if they if if they get a Matt gates in
as Speaker or if they get if they get a
sufficient enough caucus in the House
Appropriations Comm to be able to kill
funding then there goes the war effort
when then there goes the ability for
barisma to monetize the the Shale in the
Eastern region or for or Chevron
halberton shell and Exxon which all have
billion gas contracts with the Ukrainian
government all of that goes away if if
American people have Sovereign
capacities to think for themselves and
decide with those free thoughts to enact
to to have political representation that
votes for that so there's this is
there's no after smithm was modernized
and after you know after there there's
been no oversight uh there's no justice
department push back we're now in a in a
Brave New World where you know it's it's
the state Department's world and where
living in it very well said I like how
you said stakeholders at the state
department because they're supposed to
be representing the American people and
they're clearly not um are you familiar
with John Perkins and confessions of an
economic Hitman and uh 1 to 10 how
accurate is it well you know it's this
is one of these things I you know my
responsibility was cyber you know I I
didn't I wasn't in control of like a
regional desk I didn't do like you know
CE or or Mina like or Middle East North
Africa I I it was you know I was focused
on on on internet
um but you
know the fact is is is what's reflected
in there you know there's actually
almost no better example of the validity
of the John Perkins sort of theory of
the world than than a little operation
known as the Integrity initiative which
was a busted British intelligence
operation starring folks like Ann
applebomb Nina janovitz Bill Browder Ben
nmo all these people who became the
captains of censorship of the American
internet uh who had these links to
British intelligence and were also many
of them were board members several of
them on the National Endowment for
democracy which is one of the country's
oldest CIA cutouts they embarked in a
basically internet censorship campaign
in the name of stopping Russian Uh
Russian propaganda after uh after after
the Crimea annexation in
and
they one of the thing so it was run by
um a guy Christopher Donnelly or
Connelly uh who was former MI six high
ranking British military guy and one of
the internal documents and videos that
came out in the leaks was countering the
talking points related to the John
Perkins uh sort of acolytes that
actually the British state was doing
this according to a very predictable
Playbook but the fact is you had this
these weren't like random you know
activists or college professors saying
this this these were former super
heavyweight apex predators of the
National Security State plotting
operations to stop the populace from
believing a theory in a book that makes
them look bad I mean this is this is
organized political Warfare turned
domestically and anytime I see that uh I
trust the target of that far more than
the than the
prosecutor yes should we go to super
chats it's already 93 no want to add to
that I do but I think we're past Super
chats as well we are I just assumed you
going to jump in all right let's go to
super chats if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends and head over to
timcast.net
Torres says howdy people howdy Clint
thanks for the Super
Chat I'm not your buddy guy oh he was
number two today not number one says I
missed when I thought Intel officers
were like James Bond thwarting
megalomaniacs when in reality sadly
sadly they would be helping those
megalomaniacs yeah yeah when you when
you watch those movies and there's like
a super villain twirling his
mustache did you actually look DC Comics
understood this right you watch James
Bond and you're like ah these
industrialists turn out to be evil it's
like yeah and in DC Lex Luther ran for
president cuz the super villain
understood political power you know and
uh as a way evil people seek power and
they're going to seek it through
legitimate means and then be evil once
they get it and doing illegitimate
things yeah and then especially when you
have a really corrupt system you
actually start to select for the most
evil possible people you kind of
discussed this earlier when you were
speaking about the tyrannical regimes uh
we saw earlier uh in the um 20th century
or I should say later in the 20th
century mid 20th century where people
end up having to become more selfish in
order to survive I think the way the
political system actually works today is
not only do more corrupt people seek
power but we actually incentivize
corruption because it's the best way to
get ahead here's a really good one fatty
Tang says I know you're not a fan of the
death penalty that's an understatement I
oppose death penalty do you think
criminals if ruled of sound mind should
have the choice of life in prison or
death that's very very it's a very
well-crafted question and you know I'd
lean towards yes I would uh but I
actually think Exile would be would have
to be an option there as well it's not
used to be back in the day if you if you
were found guilty of a crime they would
Exile you and if you came back then they
would chase you out and so it's like
good luck surviving in the middle of
nowhere but now because everything is
basically owned and controlled there's
nowhere to Exile you to yeah suppose
they could put you on a boat and kick
you out of the ocean and say good luck
but for many people that's preferable so
that's why I said maybe instead of the
death penalty we get a big island we
fortify it secure it and say you've
resigned yourself to this fate we're not
going to kill you but you're on your own
you have you are you are excised from
the benefits of society I mean when
someone is sentenced to life in prison
if you give them the option of the death
penalty what you're basically talking
about at that point is assisted suicide
for prisoners you're basically saying so
that's really the context of the
discussion should they be able to elect
to end their own lives and I think I
think there's actually a good argument
to be made even if you believe in the
death penalty that that would be wrong
well the issue is if somebody really
wanted to end their own life they don't
need to ask you there's no reason to do
that what are the suicide rates like in
in uh in prison you know I I almost
can't help but I've seen so many
psychological studies about happiness on
you know winning the lottery versus not
and there's sort of a mean reversion to
a baseline over a certain period of time
and I just in my mind I can't place it
particularly but I I sort of have a
weird vision of people who've talked on
tape about being in the can for 35 years
and they don't necessarily look happier
or sadder than I wonder you know is is
suicide in prison even is is that like a
higher than I don't I don't know but I
was having this thought recently when we
are watching uh you know we I was
reading about a bunch of crime and I was
talking about this with my friends for
what reason did the founding fathers
decide that we could not have cruel and
unusual punishment and how would you
define cruel and unusual punishment I
certainly would make make the argument
that cruel punishment is is pointless
because being cruel doesn't serve
anything we want Rehabilitation but then
you think about like unusual forms of
punishment and I don't understand why
that's that's wrong there have been
numerous circumstances where judges have
ordered uh like young people for
instance like hold a sign on the side of
the road saying like you know I
committed a robbery or something like
this and then I thought about this a lot
of the crimes that we experience in
Chicago are due to uh indignities and
attacks on a person's honor a lot of
people think it's Gang Related it's not
the shootings in Chicago a lot of them
are like a dude would go on social media
and say this dude a weak loser what a
pathetic whiny little etc etc so
the other guy be like I'll show him and
they'd go shoot him up then the police
are like you shot him up now you're
going to prison which proves that he was
strong and hard the whole time so it's
here's the problem someone says you're a
loser the guy says I'll kill you for it
then he gets arrested and goes to prison
where he just looks hard to his his
peers and if they are in gangs they're
in prison with their gangs still
operating and again you know I I want to
to say I'm not advocating for this but I
do have a question when thinking about
these things and these Petty crimes you
look at these kids who are uh these
that's say kids but like teenagers young
adults who are ransacking and writing
what if the punishment for Mass looting
was to be spanked in public while
wearing a diaper if you're convicted and
found guilty they bring you out in
public and they give you a spanking and
then you're free to go I'm not saying we
should do that but I genuinely believe
that would stop a large portion of the
crime dead in its tracks Running Man
Thunderdome I don't know about
Thunderdome I'm just saying like the
idea of facing an indignity in front of
your peers is more terrifying than being
locked up with your peers where you work
with and harden yourself jails and
prisons where there's gangs operating
and selling drugs as it is and still
doing their illegal activities in in the
minds of many of the people that I knew
in Chicago it was just like they would
say things like when I go to jail I'm
going to in in the kids on the Southside
were like resigned themselves to assume
they would be in jail at some point and
it was totally fine it was considered
normal and they didn't fear it or hate
it at all but the idea that they would
be stripped of their dignity in public
terrifi them to the point where a lot of
these kids in Chicago kill over someone
be sming their name and I was like I'm
not saying this is a literal plan I'm
saying I tell you what if you take one
of these guys put him in a diaper and
give him a spanking they like everyone
else going be like dude I'm I'm I'm not
get me away from that because they're
terrified of all the other people they
know all the girls seeing them in this
weakened pathetic position where they're
mocked and made fun of that is more
terrifying I wonder how much of unusual
has to do with the like I think about
mandatory prison sentences sentencing
which was which was is one of these
things which constantly is volley voling
back between we we should have it we
shouldn't have it we should have it we
shouldn't should there be mandatory
sentences should judges have discretion
and you part of that is like if you
don't if something is if there's unusual
on the table you you don't even you
don't really have clear expectations of
what the punishment for a crime is going
to be and you could see they being like
you could see Justice being sort of
Highly discretionary if there's a kind
of the leeway to do things that AR I
almost I almost think unusual to be in
the sense of you know predictable rather
than than creative but I I I honestly I
honestly think sentencing people to jobs
would be more healing to a nation than
jail or prison where these just
perpetuate the uh uh the criminal
activities in a lot of ways gangs still
operate and uh in many ways someone
who's on like a minor offense who goes
to jail actually just gets hardened by
more you know by career criminals who
have been in and out of jail a ton of
times if if people were sentenced to you
know you have to go work construction
and show up like here's your sentence
you're going to be cleaning like and we
do this we do with community service and
stuff like this but I think longer term
sentences of like you are sentenced to 5
years of working at you know a
construction firm or whatever under
supervision with an ankle bracelet would
be more effective than we're going to
lock you in a box and spend money on
your life yeah and and also I think the
other point you made was super super
Salient too which was like it's not just
they get hardened they get networked
like prisons are gang systems you get
plugged into your gang and now even if
you weren't in one before that's those
that's your team now these kids who are
looting and ransacking all over the
country these kids and these young
adults they know their worst case
scenario is they're going to scream
racist like that woman at Walmart we saw
that viral video or they're going to get
locked up or pay a fine but I tell you
man I'm just saying you take a 16 17
year old who thinks he's a badass and he
and he robbed you know he he looted some
store and then you bring him out in in
public and say okay you're going to get
a spanking and not to injure to
humiliate people are going to really
think twice about whether or not they
want like I'm talking about young people
who are very concerned about whether
they look cool or not whether they fit
in whether they're popular that is a
bigger deterrent I don't think again I'm
not literally saying you do that I'm
saying the idea of a public humiliation
is is a a stronger um in disincentive
disincentive or whatever dis
disincentivizing we're going to put you
with the rest of your gang in a box
where you'll continue working or bring
back the Coliseum and if gang members
want to fight Let them fight and let's
let's let's get rid of the rule of law
and if they want to fight Let Them Fight
let people defend themselves as well and
and we have less government this is
another big issue too it used to be that
dueling was allowed and I think Oregon
still has mutual combat on the books
that if two people agree to fight right
you get M it's called mutual combat so
we used to have dueling and then you
look at like Hamilton and Burr like the
famous duel and I was reading about how
dueling ceased and it was because
younger Generations were more
Progressive and said this is barbaric
why are people dueling each other we
should make it a legal and now what you
have is rampant gun violence on the
streets of Chicago but if dueling were
still legal and you know you know they
want to do safe injection sites where
they're like we should we should allow
people to do drugs but in a safe place
okay the people in Chicago who are
trying to shoot at each other why don't
we give them a safe place to duel yeah
look if the point is that heroin can
kill you and so we want to make sure
they have a safe place to do it but
they're killing themselves I'm not
talking about oding I'm saying you are
literally dying as you're doing this
drug it will kill you in the long term
then why would they not be advocating
for dueling coliseums like Luke was
bringing up okay this guy's honor was be
smirched they used to duel back in the
day what you want to bring back safe
dueling zones so that people are hey if
the problem is little kids are getting
shot in in in the crossfire a pregnant
woman just got shot in a crossfire then
why don't you just bring back coliseums
safe dueling sites so that we can
protect the public from people who are
engaging in duels exactly you have a you
have a beef you have an issue with
someone figure it out in in a private
area where there's no government total
lawlessness Sheamus I'm personally
inviting you to a
duel of of ideas a due
Battle of ideas no no you get a duel
with pillows with my pillows it'd be
funny if it turns out like my pillow is
is somehow just like very very you know
10 times more dangerous than your
average pillow in a pillow fight and
then someone just starts destroying
everybody in a pillow fight sending
people flying this guy would put bricks
in it I don't trust him well okay let's
uh let's read some more that was a good
Super Chat by the way let's read some
more all right Raymond g Stanley Jr says
seeing big names cry about Gates saying
he's not a real conservative makes want
to let them conserve themselves to being
a speed bump Republicans only stand a
chance CU of us life's tough get a
helmet yeah McCarthy it look it's I say
I'll say it again McCarthy cutting a
deal with Democrats means there is a
Democrat majority in the house that's it
2022 is meaningless if there is a slim
majority and the Republicans are like
with our slim majority we want to
exercise it this way and McCarthy's like
nah we're just going to give Democrats
what they want then what was the point
of voting for republicans you got to
vote in more Maga type
anti-establishment types etc
etc we will grab some more Super chats
where are we at what do we have here
Pony up says myON and fresh from fresh
and fit said they would be there too can
you confirm that Tim yes uh among the
many people who will be special guests
at the event on Friday in some capacity
I don't know exactly how fresh and fit
they're here in Miami and they will be
attending and in in some way uh we'll be
we'll be working with them uh for the
event we have a lot of people who are
going to be there uh you know originally
James O'Keefe was going to be there and
then when Don Jr had to pull out we were
like James you want to just jump on the
roster and and be one of the you know
principal guests and he said yes but
there there's a lot of people are going
to be there notably uh like like Ashley
stclair will be there and um Phil leonti
will be there obviously he's on the show
um so he be he'll be there in some
capacity there's a there's a handful of
other people we're trying to we we
reached out to uh Viva he's going to be
there he is going to be there y he
confirmed yeah so it's basically just
you know uh a ton of people are going to
be there in some way uh and it's going
to be fun we interacting so you know
y'all who are in the Miami area or
nearby will see you there it's going to
be fun and then if you're an Elite
member at timcast.net
member Meetup where we're having dinner
we're going to be having a dinner in a
secret location and hanging out and it's
going to be really really fun Sheamus is
going to be the Butler and he's going to
be for things offive it's going to be a
good deal it's going to be awesome
thanks that is actual false advertising
you're ly
serving it's okay it's fine this is the
kind of credible you you had to figure
out a way to get here this is how you
did it's totally okay it's totally fine
all right let's grab some more Super
chats Noah R says don't mind me paying
the Potato Man tax Biden's presidency is
temporary but shim cast is forever
that's correct good to have you back
Sheamus thank you I appreciate that I
don't know I can't say the you know I I
I had a very serious uh medical
treatment I had to leave for that's
right and when I came back Sheamus was
gone that's right he just left I was I
was SCH to leave with the spoons ored I
was like look I'm leaving the last week
of July and then it Tim was like
look that's right you know somebody uh
that means he stole something okay did
you check everything my honey is gone oh
what what that's crazy I keep like the
accusations are stacking up I didn't say
you did anything I didn't say you did
anything you just sounds like a
GU sounds like he mention it right when
you were saying that I left that's so
strange you know what you were doing
happened to the honey these are stal
tactics well you know I don't think it
was Sheamus CU I'm not sure that the
Irish are associated with honey so yeah
so this is how we're determining whether
a crime was committed on the basis of
ethnic stereotypes I don't think that's
fair me it's it's your standard you you
you wanted Let's uh let's grab some more
Super chats and see where we at Talon 86
says Potato Man and t-shirt seller
2024 we going to run together I I don't
think so you don't I don't want to walk
with you yeah I would never appoint you
as my VP Luke doesn't want to admit it
but he was like come on can you get get
Sheamus to come out we were like no
Sheamus doesn't want to come out and he
was like dude come on at least for one
day and I was like all right fine we H
up Sheamus was like I don't know I'm
really busy it's like dude Luke is
begging you to come down and I was like
if you promise he won't be there and
here we are here we are we had to lie to
get you here it's wrong where we at
Isaac Gorski says if the FBI now says
that Maga are extremist that's it I've
had enough I'm a parent of three one
more on the way husband Catholic
conservative I am everything The
Establishment fears I am Maga and I
myself as Speaker of the House well
there you go there you are
congratulations on being Speaker of the
House SS says capitalism is not working
not even perfect I don't understand in
and outs of it but I don't care it must
be destroyed Tim you aren't too far from
BLM I love the I don't understand it but
it must be destroyed that represents
antifa so well and BLM so well cuz it's
like you
know I don't think it's fair to say that
anybody here on this show or most people
completely understand it but we
understand it quite a bit so if you say
you don't understand the ins and outs uh
we here do understand the ins and outs
we're just not perfect and we don't
understand quite literally every aspect
that would be impossible I mean I do but
you don't but the point is this
capitalism does work the problem is we
don't have that we have the erosion
through corruption and you end up with
heavy taxation you end up with the
seizure of control of property rights
and you end up with the centralization
of power because the government gives
preferential treatment to certain
companies which then aass massive power
and then revolving door between
government and they create some kind of
corporatocracy oligopoly that's not
capitalism capitalism is simple dude
invents light bulb dude gets Rich from
light bulb everybody has light in their
houses one of the problems of capitalism
because capitalism is not perfect it's
say planned obsolescence you can make a
light bulb that lasts forever instead
they make a light bulb that burns out so
you got to buy more of them that's not a
good thing okay but it doesn't that that
doesn't mean that it's not working or
that it must be destroyed quite the the
opposite capitalism is simply defined as
the private transfer uh the private
ownership and transfer of goods and
labor whereas communism is determined as
the public or government ownership of
goods and labor which basically means
you have no rights you will own nothing
and you're not going to be happy and if
you if you tell anyone you're not happy
they're going to throw you in a goog but
in a real free market there would be
someone who who would say yeah I'm going
to have a light bulb that's going to
last forever and I'm going to sell this
to you because there's an opportunity
there so we don't have that we have
government ated light bulbs that are uh
really bad for you well so the argument
is what happens is nobody wants to make
the Everlasting Light Bulb because then
they'll go out of business really
quickly they all just want to compete
and control the space and do price
fixing that's a monopoly right yes yeah
well say a monopoly you you can call it
like um 10 companies exist and all the
executives meet up and say listen if we
keep competing with each other light
bulbs are going to be a penny and we're
going to be broke why don't we all agree
that we will never sell a light bulb for
less than a dollar and they go deal
price fixing so how do you solve for
these things because these things have
happened they do happen and they happen
in free markets yes they they happen
especially with uh a lot with what
happened with David Rockefeller and a
lot of his Enterprises when he of course
was manipulating the system but uh it's
usually done through force and coercion
under the government rules and
regulations and I would still rather
have the risk of an entrepreneur coming
out and saying hey I actually have the
forever light bulb that you buy at this
particular price there still is a better
chance for that than the current system
that we have now under all these rules
and all these regulations no system is
perfect but uh the the best system I
think is a free system and uh I I think
the snake oil argument is of course just
one of many arguments of of the in
imperfectness of everything but the
biggest system that does the most damage
har harms the most people is usually a
more centralized government system and
so the question is to have a free market
would you be okay with snake wheel sales
and and and products of such I think we
already have that it's called Uh the
Trump scene the what the Trump scene
okay you have people who go into malls
and they sell balance bracelets which
don't actually do anything and the we
already have that yeah uhhuh and the FTC
issues a fine and then the company pays
the fine but made more money in profits
from the from the the fake product
anyway so it's like they'll sell $20
million in garbage pay a $5 million fine
company dissolves they reform a new
company and they sell this garbage again
that stuff already exists right I'm not
saying that government is solving for
the problem I'm saying that in a true
free market this will just persist
people will say like buy my magic rock
yeah I just want to mention I I had a
guy try to sell me one of those years
ago years ago uh I was at a mall or a
flea market or something he's like you
got to check out this balance bracelet I
was like I'm not really interested he's
like no no no you got to look at this
like like put your hand out so I put my
hand out and he like pushed down in it
to try to like knock me off my balance
and he did a little bit I was like okay
and he's like no no see what happens
when you put this on then he put on me
he like he like put it on my wrist and
then he pushed down on my hand
substantially less hard and he's like
look you didn't tip over you had better
balance I was like dude get away from
meons ridiculous sales pitch the
responsibity the responsibility is on is
on the consumer the consumer is respons
not the government so uh the way the
trick works is it's called the center of
gravity illusion that's just a basic
name for it uh you have someone stand on
one foot and what you do is have them
hold out their hands while standing on
one foot and you you grab one of their
arms and you want to push down slightly
away from their body they'll fall over
you then put the magic object in their
hand have them stand on one foot put
their arms out but this time you push
down and slightly into in the direction
of their body by only a tiny bit you're
pushing into the center of gravity so
they don't fall over and then you go
look at this now and and you can
actually push down pretty hard on
someone if you're pushing into their
center of gravity and they and and the
average person falls for the trick it's
an illusion like whoa what happened not
realizing you adjusted the angle of
force so now they're not tripping they
use that trick and the thing is all
these sales guys are taught here's how
you trick people into buying garbage
rubber bands then the FTC comes in and
says you got to pay you know5 $10
million fine they go you made $30
million already and then they relaunch
with some other garbage wait wait until
you find out what big Pharma is doing oh
I know I know I know all right let's
grab some more Super chats let's see
Ashley stclair says make sure the IRL
make sure the IRL Miami venue hides the
spoons before Sheamus arrives very good
point thank you asy I agree sickening
firstly Ashley I'm already here all
right I've been here where are you
nowhere around Tim's like I'll bring her
around for the Friday event for whatever
reason kind of participation trophy I
think he felt a little bit bad for you
participation trophy I actually didn't
invite anybody you they just showed up
it was being organized by other people
sounds you sound like you want to date
her Sheamus very angry is this the AOC
defense is this the AOC defense right
now I want to know what you did with if
you criticize somebody you what he with
spoons Luke clearly wants to date big
Pharma based on his critique of them all
right CTI says Hey Y'all please keep my
wife in your prayers as she has to put
her childhood cat down on Friday sorry
to hear man we'll we'll keep her in our
prayers David Scott says the FBI has
signaled either the end of the FBI or
the end of the US the ATF just warned
Texas ffls about cartels buying 50 Cals
no they're in you
wow 50 Cals huh well you know if uh what
was it what what government agency was
tracking the the government purchases
what which which which the ATF oh yeah
that's the same agency that actually
sent 50 bmgs to
Mexico that's so weird are you attracted
to them I think I think they're going to
have to report on themselves especially
after operation Fast and Furious and all
the horrible things that they did Fast
and Furious do you want to dat Obama or
something
yes okay uh wed OPI says Tim ever heard
of the game remember me it's about brain
chips and memory alterations along with
how people even get all their bad
memories altered or removed I would
definitely recommend giving it a play I
think I've heard of that game that's
going to be the crazy thing with norling
and there's been a lot of sci-fi about
it but when people choose to remove
memories a lot of people look at the
Matrix and it's like you can learn Kung
Fu in a minute yeah and a lot of people
are going to be like man I did not like
today just delete I want to unlearn Kung
Fu it was awful horrible experiences
yeah interal Sunshine spot kicked but uh
but also you can't you can't download
Kung Fu that's a that's the stupidest
thing I've ever heard what it requires
muscle memory and your and your muscles
to be developed you can't just know in
your brain how to you wouldn't steal a
Kung Fu don't illegally download yeah I
I think that you wouldn't steal quantum
physics everyone wants to figure out
ways to you know do do things through
taking a shortcut uh you know there's
this argument yeah you'll be able to
just download all sorts of information
about the world I'm very skeptical
skeptical that it's ever going to be
possible that the human brain is ever
going to work that way well what would
make more sense is taking a Kung Fu pill
over the period of of a year no for real
though based in kung fu pilled bro yeah
like with uh with nanotech stuff it
would make more sense that you would
instead of exercising every day you take
a Kung Fu pill and then just go play
video games and it that makes more sense
cuz it affect your muscles and
everything and the Nano could be you
know shifting and rearranging things
you'd be all soar and tired like man it
was it was crazy man yeah 4 hours of
kung fu and a pill crazy stuff all right
everybody if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
if you really do like it and head over
to
timcast.net on Twitter at Mike Ben cyber
Mike that was great thank you so much
for coming on as you guys know I'm
really big into Health that's why I
launched we are change. shop we got some
really great fish oils you guys should
check out there but more importantly
we're also doing health conscious
meetups we're doing one this Sunday 4
p.m. here in Southern Florida to get
there go to LC unfiltered.com LC
unfiltered.com and uh in related to
health news Sheamus how's the the
boozing and smoking going Charming very
Charming Luke my name is Sheamus C I run
a YouTube channel called Freedom Tunes
if you guys want to check that out we
released a video yesterday about how
difficult it is to tell the difference
between a door handle and a fire alarm
it's tough it is really hard so so watch
that video tomorrow we're actually
releasing one of my favorite videos
we've worked on I think it's going to be
really funny so I'm going to ask all of
you to go over to Freedom tunes on
YouTube and subscribe and watch out for
our upload tomorrow you're going to love
it do you hear the way Luke endorsed it
you hear that endorsement that's great
that's great Serge
FL doesn't like it it's good uh yeah I'm
just hanging out over here I'm ready for
this after show I'm surge.com on the
internet on Twix or whatever yeah let's
get to it all right everybody we will
see you all over at
timcast.net
that